how to attract money you know yeah
you're not attracting money but look
a lot of people seem to believe that
money is like this evil thing like if
you believe it's evil then you're never
going to get it i can't help you uh
there are people who think that it's uh
you know all made through connections
and who you know that may be true in a
very narrow set of industries where you
need to get your big break it's not
generally true
um if you want money if that's what you
care about if that's what you're
obsessing about then you have to give
the world something that it wants that
it does not yet know how to get in
sufficient quantity
so you just have to figure out what the
thing is that the world wants and you
have to be very hard-nosed about that
and there are lots of ways to figure out
what that is but
you also have to be really you know work
really hard at it so the only way you're
going to work that hard at something is
a you want the money but b you also have
to like it because if you don't like it
and you spend your entire life doing it
first of all you'll be miserable and
second you actually won't even be
successful because someone else who does
actually like that thing naturally will
out-compete you
so
[Music]
do
you